[Applause]
Thank You Raja for your leadership
throughout the orientation and also for
your welcoming remarks I also wish to
thank professor Ponte for his thoughtful
keynote as well as as well as our new
student body president Rocha Mehta for
hell your enthusiastic welcome well done
madam president
good afternoon class of 2022 so I asked
this question when you were here with
your parents and family members on
Sunday are you still excited to be here
[Applause]
the management team says we need to do
the leadership team you need to do this
again okay okay Carnegie Mellon class of
2022 plus are you still excited to be
here what an amazing day to be an
incoming student at CMU I'm delighted to
to be here today to kick off this
academic year with the leadership team I
want to begin by welcoming the members
of our platform group first I'm thrilled
to welcome Carnegie Mellon trustee and
Malloy who was able to join us this
afternoon
and please stand up to be recognized
thank you for joining us and I also want
to acknowledge of course Professor
Provost Lori Weingard as well as members
of the university leadership team
including our Dean's associate Dean's
vice provost and vice president I would
also like to welcome the spouses and
partners of our senior leadership team
including my wife Chris thank you all
for joining us
there's one person I want to introduce
to you just in case if you have not met
him it's usually in their MOT you're not
in my script but I do it every year
anyway I want to introduce our Dean of
Admissions Mike Sidell as all of you
know during this past year when we
received the most application in CMU's
history Mike and his team of course were
responsible for processing all of that
thank you Mike great class you know it's
been quite a week on the campus I know
this and I want to be one of the first
to extend a very special thanks to
everyone who made this orientation we
such a success including our vice
president for student affairs and Dean
of Students genic acelino and which near
levin julie schultz Gwendolyn stevens
and the entire student affairs team
countless staff members across various
academic units in colleges and
departments and administrative units
were grateful for everything that
they've done to make this such a
successful orientation
but I'm not done orientation week
success depends on relentless enthusiasm
and dedication of so many people
especially our student volunteers over
the past week I know you'll love these
pictures over the past week our 156
orientation leaders work alongside of
200 student while in tears 220th student
volunteers and countless staff at more
than 200 orientation events to make your
first few days on campus so welcoming
and so special by the way this doesn't
include does not even include 127
Resident Assistants community advisors
and housed follows who are also helping
you settled in your new homes it's
really a team effort here at CMU at this
time I want to take a moment to ask the
class of 2022 to join me in thanking our
outstanding head orientation counselors
you jumped ahead of me but I'm gonna
call their names one by one so when I
call your name our header engine cancels
please stand to be recognized Julia
Adams for stiver house Anna Jamison Beck
for more wood gardens and eat our you
can clap for them even if you're not in
those dormitory it's okay Christie Chang
and Mason miles for the hill Raghav Goya
all of course for much house
[Applause]
David Levin for the Oakland community
and Lily Marty for Donner house one more
for a special shout out before I
actually get to my next 30 minutes of in
my speech I would like to thank Emily
Newman and Sam mullet arias and the
student staff of the Activities Board
Technical Committee who volunteer every
year these are our students CMU students
to help with all the technical needs for
the orientation week please join me to
thanking everybody who contributed this
week as I mentioned during my welcome
address on Sunday the class of 2020 to
Plus has arrived at Carnegie Mellon
University at a pivotal time for
Humanity but thanks to the trailblazing
work of our faculty and students
Carnegie Mellon is positioned at the
leading edge of human progress there has
never been a more exciting time to be a
student in this constantly evolving
future the potential for a profound
impact is truly extraordinary consider
how much the world has changed just in
the last 10 years or so the first
generation of iPhones were launched in
you couldn't even order an uber until
2009 and 2010 Google Maps was not even
launched until 2008 in fact Conrad and I
used to have to print out maps before
leaving for trips right Connor he still
gets lost he said and in August 2008 the
domain name
Bitcoin org was quietly registered
online and here's a fact for you two
years later in 2010 someone famously
bought two pizzas with 10,000 bitcoins
today that would be worth close to 65
million dollars just to do the math that
would be roughly about four million
dollars a slice even Scott halls Pizza
is cheaper than that and that's not just
technology that's changing us the world
as innovation and new ideas percolate
across our society we increasingly rely
on the boldness of visual arts music and
theater to process and understand where
we have come from and to envision where
we're going it's truly an amazing time
to think about what the next decade will
bring while I can't predict the future
what I can say with confidence is that
CMU will continue to define and manage
the space where technology and humanity
intersect and our students faculty and
alumni will continue to shape emerging
intellectual domains advance human
knowledge and pursue new modes of
creative expression we not only embrace
new paradigms we define them throughout
our history no one has done that better
than CMU and no one will do it better
than you by the time you graduate when
the world will have changed once again
when you hold the keys to the future
over the last five days you've begun to
absorb the CMU culture and to learn the
rhythm of our campus life and you
continue to get your bearings and meet
new people I want you to keep in mind
what Provost Weingard men
earlier carnegie-mellon is more than
just academics we're a community
connected to one another by a common
sense of purpose pride and spirit and by
a core set of values that include
diversity and inclusion collaboration
empathy and integrity even as you pursue
your ambitions let these values guide
you in your interactions with one
another with a faculty and staff on this
campus especially in today's world when
so many people on the national stage
seem to have forgotten the value of
civil discourse and how to respect one
another we all bear responsibility for
setting a better example
remember when we recruit diverse
perspectives and ideas to our community
how people from all walks of life
succeed and consider ideas from across
the spectrum in a culture of civil
discourse we all win
class of 2022 plus today is the official
start of your college experience so
let's take a moment to appreciate where
you are and the journey you're about to
embark upon savor the sights and the
sounds as many older adults probably
have already told you college goes by so
fast so all of our students every once
in a while in fact today after you leave
this tent
stop for a moment and just look around
you're at CMU remind yourself that
you're exactly where you want to be and
that this is a wondrous moment in your
life and that you have earned this rare
opportunity to expand your horizons
with some of the most gifted scholars on
the planet the next four years will
undoubtedly be some of the most
transformative of your young lives you
will begin lifelong friendships and
discover passions that ignite academic
and professional careers CMU will change
you and you will change CMU we are so
excited for the journey that you are
about to embark on so once again the
class of 22 plus on behalf of the entire
CMU community welcome to the Carnegie
Mellon University and enjoy this most
wonderful chapter in your lives
you